cowboys moving on from don terry poe and
daryl worley this one was odd we we
heard yesterday when jerry jones was on
105.3 the fan that same appearance where
he said shut up and let me finish i
always endorse saying shut up and let me
finish although sharina i've never said
that to you and i won't i say it to sims
but not just everson griffin but also
don terry poe and daryl worley were
mentioned as potential trade candidates
it came out earlier today that if the
two aren't traded today they'll be cut
they're now cut the cowboys move on
here's what i don't understand sharina
maybe you can help me understand this
pose-based salary the balance of it as a
as a practical matter it's guaranteed he
can take termination pay and walk away
with all of it same thing for worley
both are vested veterans they can walk
away with their full pay go play for
someone else and double dip
so what are the cowboys really doing
here by getting rid of guys they're
gonna have to pay anyway
the only thing i can think is they're
sending a message mike i you know these
are two guys that have played over the
50 percent of the defensive snaps as
well and i know they haven't produced at
a high level but think about what the gm
did in the off season and of course we
know the gm is jerry jones
gerald mccoy don terry po were to your
two big signings at defensive tackle ha
ha clinton dix's safety he never made it
to the season andy dalton who who now is
hurt but okay
um
daryl worley now gone so they've made
all these offseason acquisitions that
just haven't worked out and now you see
maybe why the cowboys weren't in the
free agency market for so long dating
back to when they signed bringing a car
that's really the last time they had
gotten into the free agency market in a
in a big way like they did this year
signing a bunch of of name type guys and
none of them have worked out
particularly for the cowboys i guess
dalton's going to come back at some
point and be your starting quarterback
they're gonna assign cooper rush now to
the practice squad to be
probably the the third third or fourth
quarterback or whatever they have now uh
with ben dinucci as probably the starter
this weekend but this season has not
gone the way the cowboys thought it
would go
and now they're moving on with players
and i would venture to guess that this
these aren't going to be the last moves
that the cowboys make
yeah look they're at a point where
they're trying to figure out who wants
to be there who's willing to give full
effort one of the things i heard as it
relates to poe and worley they just
weren't
committed and they and as you said it's
sending a message to the rest of the
team but you know what if you've got
a vested veteran status
you get your base salary even if you're
cut i think the greater punishment is
keep them on the team right don't play
them keep them part of the practice
squad or keep them practicing but
inactive on game day but you want those
spots for guys that you may need so they
were done with those guys they move on
and that's that the final
tally
of the money paid to poe and worley that
isn't coming back is
6.656 million for those two players and
i fully expect that they'll elect to
receive their
their remaining salary from the cowboys
as termination pay so we'll see what
further moves the cowboys make
and you know sharing we didn't talk
about this yesterday sims and i tripped
over this today i really think someone
should call and offer something for
amari cooper because the cowboys have
plenty of receivers
they would actually realize a 12 million
dollar
net cap gain for next year now somebody
would have to be willing to commit to
paying amari cooper 20 million next year
but i i think somebody should at least
consider it if they need a receiver
because i think the cowboys maybe would
be willing to consider it if they could
recoup the first round pick they gave up
two years ago to get him and that may
sound like a stretch but remember last
year mohamed sanu got a second round
pick for the falcons at the deadline
mike i totally agree with you i think
the cowboys should put almost everybody
on the block and make it known demarcus
lawrence make us an offer
uh amari cooper make us an offer ezekiel
elliott make us an offer there are very
few players on that team cd lambs won
probably michael gallup just because of
the price you have for him and i think
he's a really good receiver
zach martin those may be the only guys
you have as off limits on on trade talks
but i would make it clear that any of
these other guys
we're open to trade and let me add one
more thing mike i'm curious and i've
thought a lot about this i want the
cowboys to end up with the number one
draft pick because i want them to be in
a situation they don't have a
quarterback for next year right i want
them to be in a situation where they
have to decide really what to do are we
going to commit to dak prescott or are
we going to roll the dice and go get
trevor lawrence and and he's going to be
our quarterback for the future i don't
see many wins left on this schedule for
them
i'm not sure they can beat the giants
i'm not sure they can beat washington
there's just cincinnati i don't think
they're going to beat cincinnati i just
don't see many wins left on this i think
they're going to have a top five pick
and i think it's a very real possibility
that they're going to start looking at
quarterbacks or have to start looking at
quarterbacks but it's going to be an
interesting thing don't you think if
they end up with a top five pick
you know we went through the rest of the
schedule game by game earlier today and
we concluded three and 13 at the very
best for the cowboys being charitable
with giving them a win like over
washington on thanksgiving or the giants
and chances are the giants would blow it
because then they would blow the first
overall pick like they blew the second
overall pick last year but yeah and
here's the thing
you will pay trevor lawrence
same
maybe even a little bit less
with the salary cap going down next year
significantly less than the 37.68
million that dak prescott would make
under the franchise tag next year you
would pay lawrence that
over a four-year rookie contract less
than what dak prescott gets for one year
so something to consider as we move
forward
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports